foreign
[Music]
applications using the latest database
services that Google cloud has to offer
my name is gurmeet goindi I go by GG and
I have the honor of having my colleague
join me in this journey good to see you
Gigi likewise so let's explain what we
mean by data-driven apps because it's a
pretty good assumption that every app
reads and writes data of some kind but I
suspect many of us could do more to
analyze that data and make it useful we
want to look at three representative
examples example one is fraud detection
for credit card transactions let's say
there's a purchase of a gym membership
on my credit card and the credit card
company wants to check if it's legit
when did you go to gym last year uh well
you know I'm planning to do more
exercise okay the point here is to
collect all the data that can be useful
what the credit card company knows about
gym purchases and what it knows about me
the second example is a reporting
example let's say a DVD store wants to
see which DVD is selling better Avatar
the way of water or top gun Maverick TTC
DVD have you heard of this thing called
screaming before well you know our team
likes old-fashioned examples
so we want to put all the sales data in
one place and then we can run any report
that we want
example three is pricing analysis let's
say that I'm planning a coupon to
increase sales I wanted to increase
profits not decrease profit right so
what's better one percent off or two
percent off in this case the example is
about running analysis on my data based
on some statistical model if you look at
where the data is coming from today
traditionally developers had to work
with two separate types of stores one
for handling transactional applications
that run the business and the other is a
data warehouse to provide insights on
how well the business is doing and uh
what about data lakes and lake houses
and object storage and all of those
things yes there are many places where
data could be but let's start by
focusing on the very common scenario
that we have here it actually works
pretty well but it also comes with the
overhead of managing monitoring and
keeping these stores in sync and let's
not forget about security I heard it's
important but with the advancement in
Cloud Technologies the boundaries
between these stores uploading and that
provides us the opportunity to make
things easier for our customers so
speaking of that we actually made some
predictions about that I'm sure all of
you read every Google Cloud blog so you
could not have possibly missed these
predictions we made in December but just
to recap our technology experts made 10
predictions for the next few years of
I.T you can see the link in the
description below there were two
predictions that we want to call out
because they're very relevant to what
we're discussing here making decisions
based on your application data the one
on the left was from Andy Goodman's the
VPN GM for database products at Google
Cloud he predicted that the barriers
between transactional and analytical
workloads will mostly disappear you know
the two locations that Gigi just
mentioned
the one on the right was from Richard
saroder of our developer relations and
outbound PM team he predicted that
multi-cloud technologies will make it
possible to freely switch your primary
cloud provider so if you're not able or
not willing to put everything on one
Cloud you'll have the means to move it
anywhere you want obviously this also
applies to your data it can be generated
by multiple apps on multiple clouds or
outside the cloud and you should be able
to analyze it wherever you want
so let's start with the first prediction
let's say that I have a database
probably many databases and a data
warehouse how do I analyze data that's
coming from both sides
let's go knock down some barriers the
three examples that we started with just
happen to match the three best friends
to integrate databases and data
warehouses wow what are the odds it's a
perfect match no match fixing here at
all so in the first example where we fly
credit card transactions we will use fed
rated queries meaning that we will query
across database and the data warehouse
in the second example where we run
report from our DVD sales we will be
streaming replication meaning that it
will stream data from our databases to
your data warehouse I do know what
streaming is GG I'm glad I'm glad to
hear that and in the third example where
we do a pricing analysis we will use
integrate analytics which means we can
skip the data warehouse because your
database is really good at running
analytical queries with that let's Dive
In
from a database nerd like me if I did it
queries are really exciting we are
bringing to fruition of how you can
gather meaningful insights by combining
historical data that's been sitting in
your data warehouse systems such as
bigquery but data that is still being
created within your transactional system
such as Cloud spanner or Cloud SQL so I
see that this query combines customer
data from bigquery with sales order data
from cloud SQL it seems to be the
canonical example of a Federated query
I'm sure it is even if I asked Bart
about of edited queries it gave exactly
the same examples
if you want to correlate customer buying
Behavior
say with their most recently placed
orders you can do that by joining the
customer buying Behavior data stored in
bigquery where the customer order tables
stored in Cloud SQL for postgres by
exerting a simple external query in
bigquery to call into Cloud SQL and
voila you have your answer no pipelines
no ETL jobs no data movements and we
even pushed down SQL processing to Cloud
SQL from bigquery
the cool thing is that the data doesn't
need to be moved it's queried all in
place
also check out credited queries between
bigtable and bigquery which uses a very
similar mechanism called external tables
okay let's move on to the second method
this one is based on replicating the
data or at least some of it from our
operational database to our data
warehouse we do that by streaming every
change as it happens on Google Cloud you
can use data stream a cloud service that
you know streams data
super easy to set up you define which
data sources to stream from and where to
stream to and it starts to securely
replicate your data it's completely
serverless and even tracks schema
changes in your database
you'll notice in the data stream
screenshot that we're replicating from
an lodb database to bigquery we're
replicating all the information about
our DVD sales actors films customer data
inventory information and all of that
amazing it makes me wonder when is
streaming the application better than
budgeted queries
I would say that streaming is a good
solution if we don't want to decide
ahead of time which reports we're going
to run maybe I want to compare two
movies today like Avatar versus Top Gun
but tomorrow I want to run a report
about inventory levels or something else
so I just want all the data in bigquery
and then I can run any report that I
want and the data will be fresh because
it's streamed continuously into bigquery
well I know who not to take to movie
theaters with me given your movie
choices
let's take this one step further what
about a world where you can run
meaningful analytics or one might say
operation analytics write against your
transaction database no streaming
changes no setting up pipelines no
Federation of anything
with that in mind we developed the
columnar engine for our alloy DB
database Allied EPS calendar engine
makes analytical queries run up to 100x
Faster by keeping frequently query data
in an in-memory columnar format for
faster scans joins and aggregation it's
right there in the database for you to
use okay let's put integrated analytics
aside for a moment can you tell us more
about what alloy DB is would love to
lydb is our fully managed postgres
compatible database that we built to
help you cost effectively modernize from
Legacy databases or scale your existing
postgres apps
it's Google's newest Cloud database with
all the goodness of postgres and all the
goodness of Google technology and in our
performance test all idb is four times
faster than standard postgres and two
times faster than Amazon's comparable
postgres compatible service for
transactional workloads I think I know
which service you mean GG I'm sure you
do yes that one and the lidb is up to
100 times faster analytical queries and
scales to thousands of ecpus for read
workloads it also provides a four nines
no-nonsense SLA which is inclusive of
maintenance
we took a hard look at how we can remove
or reduce toil for postgres Developers
and brought in a ton of machine learning
algorithms for vacuum management memory
management and how you move data across
caching tiers and storage tiers
lastly we integrated a word xci service
so developers can invite vertex AI
models straight from the SQL query nice
so let's go back to the other prediction
about multi-cloud I think we've
presented some good options today for
running data-driven apps on Google Cloud
but it breaks my heart to admit that
some databases are not on Google cloud
and some analytics don't run there
either maybe they never will
you've seen several scenarios Gigi where
they need to run in other places right
correct sometimes people can't move to
the cloud as fast as they want their
workloads are restricted to on-premises
Data Centers because of the complexity
of their applications the complexity of
their Network topologies or they need to
run multiple clouds or need to run a
disconnected fashion due to regulatory
or data sovereignty requirements or they
may be running their applications at the
edge like a retail store or a telka
facility
customers tell us that they want to
eliminate unfriendly licensing
relationships expensive fees vendor
lock-in faster than they're able to
re-platform everything to cloud and they
asked us to find a path to support them
in their In-Place Point Edition Journey
with lidb they also want us to support a
tier one provider like Google when they
are on this modernization journey with
lidb so with that we're really excited
to tell you about alloy DB Omni a
downloadable version of alloy DB that
you can run anywhere we introduced it a
few weeks ago but wanted to give some
more information today that will be
useful for application Developers
ludb Omni uses the same engine as the
cloud version of alloy DB and it's still
100 compatible with postgres it's based
on the postgres Kernel and uses the same
wire protocol and it supports postgres
extensions and flags but it's more than
two times faster than postgres for
transactional workloads and it's up to
100 times faster for analytical queries
because it includes the alloy DB
columnar engine off did you see a
downloadable version I'd be like a cloud
company we are but we want to meet
people where they are sometimes you need
to modernize an older application
without moving it to the cloud and it's
not your imagination we actually have
AWS and Azure logos here alloy DB Omni
will run great on those clouds yeah I
was wondering about this logo as I also
noticed that the slide says more than 2x
faster than postgres but a little idb in
the cloud is 4X faster than a postgres
thanks for paying attention it's because
of the difference between the high
performance storage that we have in
Google cloud and the storage available
on premises the cloud scale is so much
better still it's a huge performance
gain in both cases and in terms of price
aloe dibi Omni is an Enterprise level
database at a fraction of the cost of
Legacy databases so it's a great way to
modernize applications to postgres you
might be wondering what the installation
is like nobody wants to go back to the
old school installation scripts we tried
to make our idb Omni as easy to install
and use as possible it's packaged as a
container all one needs to do with
install Docker pull the container
repository download and run the
installer and there you have a
commercial database up and running to
handle some of your most demanding web
applications under five minutes to patch
a database just repeat steps two to four
and you're good to go and now that you
have a downloadable database that runs
analytical queries up to 100 times
faster your decision making is much
closer to real time you can get business
insights from your operational data by
running queries directly on the database
and by the way I was looking for a way
to illustrate a 100x difference in speed
so I looked up the speed of a Boeing 787
on Wikipedia and it has a maximum speed
of 690 miles per hour a good runner can
do about 6.9 miles per hour which is uh
equivalent to finishing a marathon in
just under four hours yeah we don't want
adjustment queries to feel like a real
Marathon exactly
now you have you may wonder how we do
this how we make the analytics go 100x
faster so let's take a deeper look there
we implemented the engine as a postgres
extension so it's transparent to your
apps and they don't need any code
changes to use it
secondly the machine learning algorithms
move the data between dram the ultra
fast cache and the storage depending on
your usage pattern giving you the
performance of memory and the scale and
economics of persistent storage
processes for a long time have been
shipping with simd instruction set which
makes vectorized operations go really
fast
now if these operations are executed
against data stored in in-memory columns
then we can speed up those operations by
a couple of orders of magnitude alloy DB
Builds on these Hardware enhancements
and brings this technology to postgres
and extend the lid Beyond me where you
can extract a lot more value out of a
CPU no matter where you run your
workload
also took this opportunity to bring in
some of the unique techniques like
storing min max values and learn
metadata alongside the data stored in
the economic structure to further give
you an intelligent response from the
governor engine
these techniques for a long time were
only available in expensive commercial
databases
and all of the other benefits with the
added advantage of Google machine
learning makes the user experience
simple and transparent so all of that is
happening behind the scenes and I don't
need to do anything exactly let me give
you an example of a machine learning
algorithm in the rdb the lidb memory
manager uses machine learning to predict
your memory usage and automatically
adjust memory is required for your Os or
system task versus the database almost
completely preventing the dreaded out of
memory events or rooms or you might also
say no more rooms and no more loops
after all things ml these algorithms
will keep getting better over time but
don't take my word for it let's do a
quick demo because Randall and remember
your analysis uh for your example you
have of an analyzing discounts one
person is better or two percent let's
earn that one on lydb or omnis Gunner
engine and see what we get
[Music]
well thank you and welcome to this
demonstration of how fast analytics are
on Ali DB Omni
ledb Omni is postgres compatible you can
see here I'm running PG admin which is
an advanced postgres application for
managing postgres I'm managing several
postgres instances including an alloy DB
instance on our cloud service
and this instance which is actually
running on my Windows laptop with a
Debian Linux virtual machine this is the
platform where I'm going to be doing
this demo you don't need a big Hardware
platform to run alloy DB Omni it'll run
anywhere you want including on the edge
so for this demonstration I loaded a
tpch database with the free Hammer DD
tool I loaded over a billion rows into
the database
you could run this very same Benchmark
using the same tools the scenario is
that I'm running an online store that's
very very busy on Black Friday thousands
of orders are being entered
I want to find out right now if I give a
larger discount will I actually get more
Revenue all right so let's run this
query and find out how long it takes to
run without the columnar engine
and as you can see it is running it's
going to take a long time I'm going to
use the miracle of video editing to move
forward into the future
so you don't have to wait for the query
to finish okay we're back the query ran
in quite a long period of time it ran in
nine minutes and 56 seconds
that's pretty long and the result though
was encouraging when I offered a two
percent discount I did indeed get more
Revenue than with a one percent discount
well something else happened while we
were waiting for the query to finish
there was an outage in Priority One
trouble tickets were filed users could
no longer enter new orders and I caused
it by running these analytical queries
let's take a look at the top command in
Linux very little the CPU is available
maybe 12 percent and there's massive
waiting for Io
so now let's see how fast this query
runs with the columnar engine I don't
need to make any code changes it
automatically uses the columnar engine
if it's appropriate okay how fast is it
going to run the other query without the
columnar engine ran in over nine minutes
let's see Click Boom
less than a second there's even more
good news I don't have to have indexes
on these columns so if I do have them
for analytics I can drop those indexes
and my transactions get faster in the
system so not only is the columnar
engine really fast it can make the
entire database faster and with Ally DB
Omni it actually gets faster the more
you use it due to the autopilot machine
learning algorithms that are managing
the database
well alloy DB Omni sure is fast give it
a try you can download it right now
thanks so much for watching
[Music]
you can always take it for a spin
because a lidb Omni is free for
developer use and we as we said earlier
it's really easy to get set up and get
started so if you're eager to give this
product a try this is how we put a link
in the description below go there sign
up and give us your feedback
now you can make both of the predictions
we talked about come true remove the
barriers between transactional and
analytical workloads and run the same
database alloy DB everywhere on and off
Google Cloud
and before we go we also want to invite
you to check out our entire database
product line we mentioned several
services today Cloud SQL lodb spanner
bigtable data stream those are all
relational or key value you can explore
additional options here there are
in-memory and document database options
and a database migration service to help
you migrate from other databases to
Google Cloud
thanks everyone for joining our session
it's always fun for us to talk about
databases and The Innovation that is
happening in this field we hope we spark
some ideas and Concepts that you can
leverage in your application development
Journey have a great Google I O and see
you at Google next bye
[Music]
foreign